con un nuevo ciclo electoral de medio
término las miradas están nuevamente
enfocadas en Georgia un estado que fue
clave para la carrera por la casa blanca
y para darle a los demócratas un
estrecho control de la cámara alta con
un aura de temor entre los trabajadores
electorales por las amenazas que
sufrieron en 2020 tras las infundadas
acusaciones de su puesto fraude
electoral de Donald Trump tras su
derrota Joe biden ganó el que había sido
el bastión republicano desde 1992 ha
sido una lucha a conseguir trabajadores
electorales en todo Georgia muchas
personas debido a los últimos ciclos no
han querido serlo Vanessa fue una de las
trabajadoras acosada y sometida a la
presión política algunos de sus
compañeros No han querido retomar sus
puestos en nuestros comicios ella no
temo volver
si permito que la gente mente mide así y
me quite algo que disfruto hacer ellos
tienen el poder sobre mí y si alguien
tiene poder sobre ti entonces creo que
puede hacerte cualquier cosa que quieran
lo hago para asegurarme de Que todos
tengan el derecho que tengan derecho a
votar puedan venir y hacerlo para
facilitarles el proceso para asegurarme
de que entiendan el proceso
la polémica envuelve también a los
principales candidatos en la carrera por
uno de los escaños en el senado el
conservador Walker es jugador de fútbol
americano y firme anti abortista está
acusado de haber pagado un aborto a una
de sus exparejas su rival el pastor
demócrata Rafael warnogh también fue
acusado por su exmujer de violencia
machista ambos niegan las acusaciones
sabes es una elección de alto perfil
Creo que muchas de las afirmaciones del
último ciclo electoral han sido
desacreditadas así que tengo la
esperanza de que este sea un ciclo
electoral tranquilo Georgia podría
volver a tener las llaves para que los
demócratas mantengan el control del
senado en un estado donde las nuevas
leyes electorales apuntan a reducir la
participación de las minorías en el
proceso democrático